[Applause]
excellent work sir come with me no more
they need to be pulled from the sky is
why it might be of help if you tell me
what you're looking for the span of
trays it's sort of trees will halt and
right over the rest this is not that
deal agree depends
yes so much depends
yes
this is the place I'm sure of it
do you see how these creates a perfect
form yes
leave them clear the rest what are we
building the sky table these will be the
legs sky table head I always to stride
over the trees and study the clouds and
the smoke from wellbut no man in New
France will possess such a view I have
never heard of such a thing I have
invented it sketch there is no precedent
for such a thing we started once I have
been granted a wife by decree of the
king and I wish to complete the table
before we are properly bound what I'm
Marie alright he's not my wife sir mari
not is the wind ed Oh y'all tell me Sal
there's a man such as yourself think of
all day besides the bites of the axe I
mean they think of nothing nonsense
the bird of thought enters us all what
vapors in your mind I think sometimes of
man brother he who is dead yes this is
what families are like the ones who have
come and asked from this world push us
to find new fields it is the fear of
departing this realm without leaving a
mark he must do better than this dead
brother he must set a course for you
I almost started with this and Marie
must not know a word of this now I need
to be able to trust you
you'll have my word
good
[Music]
you